j'ai du mal à parler aux machines - ok
[Musique]
pour les médias d'aujourd'hui sont la
caisse de résonance d'une élite qui a
complètement divorcé d'avec le peuple et
qui traite les sujets qui la concerne
elle et qui ne concerne pas les citoyens
ou qui la concerne les concerne très peu
mécanique nécessaire mais largement
inutiles qui tourne en vase clos et
qu'il n'a plus de prise sur le réel on
l'a vu à l'occasion des mouvements
sociaux on raconte une histoire
officielle
les éléments de langage de l'exécutif
sont repris sans beaucoup d'esprit
critique sans analyse ni rotule lacroix
fait un baromètre annuel de la confiance
dans les médias mais jim and stream
reculé de manière considérable
ah non c'était pas mieux avant du temps
de la rtf la censure elle est beaucoup
plus il ya plus de chaînes ces chaînes
n'ont pas été un gage de pluralisme et
de démocratie
en terme de qualité dans la conduite des
interviews dans le maniement de la
langue française
on m'a très largement régressé avec des
émissions de télé-réalité ou des
magazines qui lance en fin de la pub à
outrance qui sont là crétiniser à
quelqu'un l'avait théorisé l'ancien
patron tf1 moi mon boulot c'est de
vendre du temps de cerveau disponible à
coca cola tout était dit
[Musique]
nous on n'y échappe on est dans un gie
les indés qui regroupe 130 radio
commercialisé par tf1 donc j'ai voulu
rompre en bénéficient d'une pub
mutualisent et on peut dire ce qu'on
veut il n'y a pas un annonceur qui va
nous appeler en disant parce que c'est
que cette histoire on a un actionnaire
unique qui ne dépend pas des commandes
de l'état est complètement indépendant
qu'ils nous fichent une paix royale et
il nous demande simplement de faire des
débats de dire toujours la vérité avec
de la hauteur de vue de pas se
transformer en procureur ou un homme
politique ou en moraliste est que plus
les faits sont graves lui convient
d'avoir du recul donc ont assez de
chance et ses deux chances on les
saisies ont les saisi à bras le corps et
on ne sait en faire bon usage
[Musique]
ça me laisse totalement indifférent
parce que d'abord il est inopérant
aujourd'hui le simple fait d'avoir été
dans la rue pendant un an pour montrer
ce que vivaient les gilet jaune m'a valu
de la part du système ce genre de
qualificatif ne revendique pas gilet
jaune je suis leurs conseils et leur
goût
si la question est de savoir si j'ai
toujours de la sympathie
et si je trouve leur combat juste et
toujours de la sympathie pour le gilet
jaune et je trouve qu'ils ont beaucoup
apporté à la société française par leur
transversalité parle horizontalité et
que depuis les gilet jaune
plus rien n'est comme avant donc merci
merci beaucoup l'egypte
[Musique]
il ya beaucoup de journalistes
éditorialistes militants ils sont
militants de même de leur nombril et
militants de l'exécutif savent qu'ils ne
le disent pas ils sont militants de leur
corporation
donc moi je préfère quelqu'un qui
affiche la couleur
moi je crois pas du tout à l'objectivité
journaliste est une tarte à la crème
l'objectivité n'existe pas on a toujours
on a toujours un an ce qui existe c'est
la subjectivité et la sincérité mais si
vous dites voilà qui je suis
voilà d'où je parle voilà ce que je fis
mais voilà mon propos au moins c'est
clair
après on adhère on adhère face si vous
êtes engagés plutôt à gauche que vous
voulez vous faire passer pour un proto
libéral ça va être un peu compliqué mais
si vous ne mentez pas si vous êtes un
journal d'opinion il faut le dire mais
simplement 7
il n'y a pas de hiatus pour moi mais il
faut annoncer la couleur
je trouve que c'est un peu un faux débat
puisque quand je regarde par exemple
l'interview de juan branco il hier sur
bfm qui était proprement scandaleuse une
honte qu'on devrait montrer dans toutes
les écoles de journalisme pour le
contre-exemple absolue c'est de la haine
à l'état pur ça c'est du militantisme
déguisée au nom d'une pseudo objectivité
en fait c'est le sait la france en
marche en temps de paix imaginez qu'une
journaliste se comporte comme ça dans
des temps un peu plus trouble ça fait
quand même prix
[Musique]